Hunter refuses to share his finances
with the baby mama who gave him lap
dances
because when Junior needs a new pair of
shoes Hunter starts singing the blues
court documents reveal the smartest man
Joe Knows is trying to weasel out of
support payments to his love child with
a former exotic dancer also known as a
stripper
even though the judge okayed paying
entirely with one dollar bills
at first Hunter denied the kid was his
until the court matched his DNA which
they scraped off a ceiling at a motel 6.
oh damn yeah Hunter is reportedly trying
to lower the amount due to a change in
his financial circumstances because as
we all know inflation has made it really
hard to afford child support and crack
cocaine so he claims he's broke
meanwhile judge Rudolph Contreras seen
here will not make records public in
Hunter's firearm case you recall
Hunter's gun ended up in a trash can in
2018 which sounds Shady Until you
realize it was dumped by his brother's
widow whom he was banging at the time
and who can't relate to that
the Obama appointed judge ruled Hunter's
privacy outweighs releasing the records
to the public
privacy if this judge cares about
hunter's privacy hold him in contempt
until he puts on some pants
we're talking about a man who saved more
dick pics than Richard Nixon's
biographer
yes I'll take some Applause that is good
I get it good there you go that is why
you are number one yes I will not back
away from a joke as long as it's married
to a person named dick then it's not
that kind of joke see you can learn from
the master here cat what do you make of
this story he had I mean you know he is
look whatever he does he talks about
taking responsibility this is his kid
this kid is going to grow up knowing
that his dad is running his uncle's
president yeah I mean it's really yeah
it's yeah because I stopped listening
halfway through that is his uncle no
wait no yes
I think we should just move on
um I think it's also gonna especially be
tough because the kid can just go on the
internet and find out that like his dad
also has snot rockets that make seventy
five thousand dollars each yeah with his
paintings he just shoots the paint out
of his nose and boom 75 grand my snot
Rockets aren't that lucrative even
though I can get some distance sometimes
but still you don't have any excuse it's
not like he doesn't have ways to make
money or he doesn't have enough
connections to power he's the last
person who can can claim something like
that
I feel that you have a strong uh
uh just the way you're looking at me I'm
frightened
yeah I really wish I had my sunglasses
right now and whatnot and whatnot yes
um
I I feel the pain of Child Support
ridiculous child support
but
you've just gotta do you just gotta pay
that man you just gotta do it yes and it
sucks but when you have as many cash
Avenues as he does
it's it's pathetic it's not like he
doesn't have a few friends in China that
could cut him a check yes you know it's
like or yeah Ukraine he will engage in
corruption for anyone but his child yeah
yeah but he can get money from anywhere
you know if he cut back to just one
hooker a week yes
he could support my kids also yeah
that's true that's true he spent so much
money on on so many bad things yeah but
uh but also you know with the whole
right to life thing I also think like
men kind of would get a bad you know
because we don't have a choice in the
matter we should at least be able to you
know fan and the little guys you know
just move on from it what if this was a
trump a trump a trump son uh making art
out of his snot thing and strippers
knocking them up
you know we yeah I mean we never hear
the end of it but the thing about this
is he's
sticky like oh I can't afford child
support I mean look conditions have
changed but he's not very smart because
if he has to go to a court and say I
want to get my child support reduced
because my financial situation is then
what does the judge say let's see
let me have a look at where your income
stream is and that's where they get it
so he is now going to be on the record
for where is all that money go who you
know who's the big guy where did that
money go crack's not a write-off no
matter how much no but you know they got
Al Capone on tax evasion not on killing
half the people in Chicago Rob if your
dad is a hunter and your mom's a
stripper this kid's going to be in an
extrovert
yeah he's uh he's such a lucky lucky
little kid yes he is
um I I as you know I'm not a licensed
psychologist in the state of New York
but you do look like one you do
um
he is um he uh obviously is recovering
we hope a drug addict he is an influence
Peddler he's a forgetful computer owner
we know that yes
um he's doing all this and now he's now
he's a deadbeat dad he's doing all this
stuff to get attention and the media and
like the New York Times and CNN they
refuse to give it to him even though he
desperately craves it so they don't
really want to cover this story and he's
going to do more and more crazy in
outlandish someone's going to get hurt
yeah he's going to like you know try to
do something he wants to this guy wants
to be on the front page I say for the
sake of all of our safety he should be
on the front page he should come on this
show we've extended the invitation to
Hunter for uh he'd be part of the panel
maybe offer him a check yes exactly I'll
buy one of his paintings he's just weird
he'll put a stripper through college but
not his child yes exactly
but that's why they do it yes
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else